hey guys Pete here this will be the
first of several spoiler recap videos
I'll be making over the next week since
there isn't any action or filming going
on for season seven right now the news
will probably be slow so I decided to go
back and put all the stuff we know
already together in a handful of videos
that are just organized so you can keep
up with all of what we know about the
different characters and storylines as
the title suggests this is full of
spoilers it's almost entirely spoilers
for season seven cast news and filming
so if you don't want to know what's
going to happen in season 7 please stop
watching you can check out my are the
gods real non spoilers video to learn
about my book giveaway if you're spoiler
adverse and everyone else please stick
around to the end so you can learn how
to enter with that out of the way let's
jump right into it so in this video I'm
going to go over all the characters who
don't have a big enough story to have
their own video like characters who we
haven't seen for a while they're gonna
pop back up like you know Gendry
so I basically went back and watched all
my previous spoiler videos and pulled
out the relevant information for this
particular category one of the first
things that was going around in the
speculation mill and was actually a
story with legs for a while I mean
people were reporting on this was that
Angela Lansbury was going to be in
season 7 that turned out to be
completely false and if you really think
about it what the hell would she play in
Game of Thrones anyways she's not in it
and another story that got popular
around that same time was that Rhaegar
Targaryen had been cast which I'll be
honest I didn't like the theory at the
time and I was hoping it wasn't true but
after I saw the history and lore about
the tourney at Harrenhal and how they
left out Rhaegar for the most part in
that I'm leaning towards this is
probably going to be a flashback Rhaegar
the obvious idea of what Rhaegar would
be in a flashback for will relate to
Lyanna stark I'm guessing it would come
in a vision that bran has and it could
even be their wedding which a lot of
people speculate may have happened on
the Isle of faces when the story was out
and I took that photo the one here I
actually
saved it as fake Raigarh so I had to go
look him up real quick his name's Devin
Oliver and he is in a band called I see
stars and the whole rumor started when
he said he may have been in season seven
of Game of Thrones so he looks like if
you could look up it go google him he
looks like Rhaegar he might as well be
Rhaegar so let's move on one of the
things that got me most pumped and
actually started me on the path of
making a weekly spoiler report was an
early report we got about the Greyjoy's
and the fact that they had both been you
know Theon and Yara had both been
filming what looks like a battle at sea
where they be going up against their
uncle the evil Euron Greyjoy at this
time we heard that one of the sand
snakes would be killed and that either
Theon or Yara what would be taken
captive by your own later we got
confirmation on most of those things as
we saw your on coming to town to present
the sand snakes and Yara to Queen Cersei
Iran's only been I think in two episodes
of the show so far so a lot of people
don't really think of him as an exciting
character but anybody who's read the
books has definitely pumped up about
this we found out that he will be
joining forces with Cersei almost for
sure and I'll get more into what we know
about that when I go in to Cersei story
in the season in a separate video as
mentioned we saw that Yara is the one
that gets captured and we got a lot of
information about what Theon will be
doing in the meantime we learned that he
will be meeting back up with Jon and
actually saw photos of this reunion
which didn't go well and that basically
after he gets separated from Yara and
the rest of the Greyjoy fleet during the
battle with Joran he ends up going to
Dragonstone I'll talk more about the
homecoming reception part and the king
in the north video but we also got some
footage that shows Theon getting his ass
kicked by the Ironborn so from that we
got some you know some set rumors or
saying that you know they were basically
done with the honor he must have done
something and wasn't very honorable and
maybe he left yarr behind or something
along those lines so he paid
the price the biggest return character
is obviously Gendry I mean this guy's
been gone forever and it's been the you
know subject of endless amount of memes
and discussion about where he might be
we first saw the actor Joe Dempsey who
plays him at an airport in Belfast which
sent up the alarm bells and then we got
full-on shots of him in scenes at Zumaya
where he was wielding a war hammer with
the Baratheon sigil on it there's so
many things that have happened since
then that I almost forget about how
awesome this actually is I mean zoom a
was that set location where basically
the paparazzi had an open shot to be
able to film things that were going on
while the cast and crew were filming and
we literally had a video of the entire
scene where Tyrion and davos are talking
to gold cloaks and Gendry pulls out a
war hammer and beats their asses we also
got a couple other shots of him later on
where we saw that he has re-entered the
fold we don't know what he's doing but
he's definitely on the right side so
we'll probably get to learn a little bit
more of that once the actual trailer
start to come out we're really sure what
Jorah was gonna be up to this season and
we got quite a lot to go off of here
he was first spotted in Belfast early on
which hinted he might be filming in the
studio's up there or he could have been
in some scenes in the north then we got
a full-on shot of him in a boat when he
was approaching Dragonstone so we'll get
more into all of his story when we talk
about Daenerys in her own video
everyone's favorite half pint Lyanna
Mormont is back and she looks cool as
hell with tormund we saw that on
Instagram first and then we got some
really cool shots of her around the set
in Belfast she looks like she sprouted
up a little bit in the off season but
she's still super cool and wearing her
nice-looking Northman gear and around
the same time it looked like she would
probably be shooting scenes with Davos
Arya and Jon Snow which is a pretty
incredible lineup when you think about
it other than when she was at the set we
don't get to see much because she only
filmed in the North which we don't
really get much set pictures out of
from any of those locations up there
Thoris of Mir is back and he is supposed
to play a larger role in season seven
according to the reports at the time our
favorite eighth son may be important
because of his connection to the red God
since Melisandre was banished by Jon we
know from the end of last season that he
was headed north and we know from some
of the things we've seen here that
they'll actually be joining up with
quite a few people for a giant battle
that goes on up north of the wall so
yeah he sounds like he's probably going
to die up there but you know we don't
really know because like I said there
are no leaked scenes and things like
that coming out of Belfast there were a
handful of mystery characters that
showed up on the set there was this
little kid who you know looks like he's
a son of a northern house and a mystery
redhead who initially was reported to be
a body double for Sansa but it turns out
that these two are likely car starts
she's probably a Lascar Stark who
stories obviously a lot different than
it is in the books but it you know he's
probably a brother or some other such
thing we found out that dollar said
we'll be involved obviously the new Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch will be up
north at the wall but we found out that
he'll actually be meeting up with bran
which sparked off some serious
speculation about brands mark from the
night king but we can't really connect
the dots here we know bran will probably
be in Winterfell later due to what we
know about mirrors traveling and some
other things we've seen but as much as
everyone including myself has thought
that the wall would be coming down at
the end of the season there really
hasn't been much as far as evidence is
you know to this point of that happening
so we're going to have to wait and see
exactly if that's the you know that's
really what's going to happen or if
brands is going to pass through talk to
the Nightwatch and go see what's
happening over at Winterfell we did get
a one shot of a taxi cab driver waiting
for Edmure Tully's the actor who plays
at mera Tolly as he was coming back from
Belfast so it's pretty likely that Arya
is going to meet with him before she
leaves the Riverlands but that's lit
that's literally it we
we know he's there we know he went to
Belfast but nothing else about it
as mentioned Muir was spotted on set and
she's obviously up north but what was
interesting here was as that one of
these photos was spotted at the money
glass studios where they usually shoot
winterfell scenes and they don't suit
shoot anything else there it's not like
a multi-purpose thing so this is a
pretty good indication that mirror and
brand do make it to Winterfell before
the end of season 7 now we have a pretty
good idea that John won't be there
anymore at that time but Sansa and Arya
should be so that's going to make for a
gigantic stark family reunion there was
one shot of the set that was rumored to
be Melisandre from Spain but it isn't
likely the case there was woman in a red
cloak photograph from a very long
distance but other than that there's no
supporting evidence that Carice van
Houten was in Spain during that time
it's really not much else to say about
it so let's hope that we still get a
chance to get some Melisandre in the
next season I mean yeah Thoreau's could
carry the red gods bag for a little bit
but we definitely need some Melisandre
action one interesting character that
popped up in both Belfast and Spain was
Francis the little bird you might not
know her by name but she was involved in
the murdering of pycelle at the end of
season six and it's pretty big news
because she's officially working for
Qyburn now and you know obviously Queen
Cersei but her showing up when she did
actually hints to an enduring loyalty to
Varys what you know is that's got to be
something we think about is what kind of
power he can pull when it comes to those
little birds that work for him with all
those years once he arrives at King's
Landing which I'll talk about when we
get into a different video an
archmaester who I couldn't remember
archmaester ebro's was cast and there we
also got a shot of maester wolkan he's
gonna be back you know he was the
Meister at Winterfell when the Bolton's
were holding it he was the guy who was
kind of set off to get Willa and bring
her and the boy to Ramsay so that he
could have the dogs eat her this was
kind of interesting that that
archmaester you bros thing was kinda
interesting because when you look into
what he does he's a healer and we had
this Jim Broadbent the guy from Harry
Potter and all kinds of other stuff he's
a pretty well-established actor
we had these rumors that he was cast
which he has been and a lot of us were
hoping it was going to be from Morrow in
the mage but now it looks pretty much
like he was actually for archmaester
ebro's who will play a part in helping
Sam wall hear the greyscale for
Jorah we also heard news that tycoon the
stars from the iron bank will be coming
back and he'll most likely look be
looking to get paid from House Lannister
who's now firmly seated on throne
we know that Cersei wasn't really in a
hurry to pay them back so that's
probably going to lead to some chaos of
some sort we got a shot of Bronn showing
up in cafes and we'll get way more into
what he's doing when we talk about Jaime
because he's obviously going to be
involved in the battles at Jaime's side
Randall and dick and Tarly are going to
be back this season and we know that
James Faulkner is going to be continuing
to play Randall and that Tom hopper has
been cast to replace the guy who played
dick and Tarly last season
Tarly he's kind of get themselves into
it and I'll talk about that in a
different video but these guys will
definitely be playing a major role in
season 7 as well we also had word that
Conor McGregor of the UFC will be a
pirate on Euron ship the silence that
Uncle Benjen is coming back for a scene
up north
most likely with his nephew Jon Snow
Littlefinger of course is involved but
I'll talk about him when I talk about
the other Starks up north the sand
snakes as mentioned got trapped and
captured or whatever and one of them is
supposedly killed off Sam and Gilly
showed up and did some scenes in old
town where they look like they're going
to be taking off and going back north
and it has been confirmed that because
Jorah is the son of the old bear jr.
Mormont who was the Lord Commander at
the wall when Samwell first showed up
Sam feels compelled to try to help him
and cures his greyscale at the Citadel
when the other masters won't help out so
that's pretty much it for the satellite
characters if you didn't hear someone's
name yet or I didn't go into their story
it's coming up in a following video I'm
gonna do these right after the other
hopefully each day if I can we'll just
have to see what happens but the next
one is going to be about the king and
the North Jon Snow and his story
throughout season seven that we know so
far so please tune in and check that out
soon make sure you like this video if
you liked it and if you want to enter
the book giveaway subscribe now if
you're not already subscribed and leave
a comment on this video or any of the
other ones where I mention this
particular giveaway way it works is once
I hit 28,000 subscribers I will send one
lucky commenter a copy of the 20th
anniversary of a game of Thrones by
George R Martin there's a link in the
description to check it out if you
haven't seen it yet it's awesome it's
Illustrated it's just the best so
subscribe like and comment and hopefully
you'll be the winner that's it for now
guys thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon